nous accueillons notre therion du samedi
la theurre ce soit victoire maçon ou
[Applaudissements]
encore mon foie
[Musique]
à l'âge de 17 ans alors que vous faites
du shopping avec votre maman vous êtes
repéré par un chasseur de mannequins et
bientôt vous défilé pour les plus grands
marques de haute couture du monde un
seul problème c'est que pour rentrer
dans les robes des défilés c'est taille
32 alors votre histoire vous le raconter
dans un livre intitulé
jamais assez maigre publié aux éditions
les arènes et à 20 heures dans sa lutte
à
victoire bonsoir
[Applaudissements]
vous êtes né le 27 mai 1992 à paris père
ingénieur physicien en hautes
technologies
mère artiste plasticienne vous est
scolarisée dans une école catholique
où la règle numéro 1 c'est l'obéissance
et comme vos parents le souhaitent parce
que vous êtes obéissante
chaque année vous êtes classé dans les
premières de la classe
arrivé en terminale vous postulez pour
sciences po et hypokhâgne et puis le
destin frappe
[Musique]
le destin nous sommes en mai 2010 vous
faites du shopping avec votre mère dans
le marais quand un petit homme noir
tu sers ce choix
j'y peux rien s'approche de vous et vous
dit
tu n'as jamais pour cette mannequin je
travaille pour élites appelle moi je
peux faire de toi la prochaine claudia
schiffer ou sont est flatté tout à fait
bâle s'est absolument pas ce à quoi je
m'attendais étant donné qu effectivement
j'étais focalisé sur les études et mes
notes j'avais jamais pensé à moi prenez
rendez vous avec le petit homme noir
excuse moi
cet homme est noir où il est petit
habillés en noir
les petits et noir mais bon pourquoi on
l'appelle le petit homme noir
c'est comme il l'écrivait le mieux à
l'époque je connaissais pas son prénom
mais c'est un petit homme noir pourquoi
dire qu'il aimait ce qu'est ce que
j'aurais pu dire c'est un petit andrew
oui mais ça c'est une couleur de jeu
enfin ça rajoute alain prix vous pas le
fait qu'ils soient noirs donc on peut
l'appeler petit mois pour moi fameuse un
drain battu le chili on va l'appeler
c'est ben oui voilà voilà
et alors
à partir de là tout va aller très vite
l'objectif c'est la fashion week de new
york huit semaines plus tard mois
alors dès notre arrivée chez hills est
prise en charge par florence
spécialiste des top models elle vous
mesure de la tête aux pieds et elle vous
dit pour les photos 36 ça passe mais
pour les défilés ce sera plutôt 32-34
meta huit semaines oui et donc ça
voulait dire tu as le temps pour maigrir
qui est très fastidieux dans la mode
c'est qu'on ne vous dit pas il faut que
tu m'aies grèce l'objectif effectivement
c'est passé de 58 kg à 48 kg alors vous
fixé comme objectif de perdre un kilo
par semaine et chaque jour au lieu de
manger trois repas vous mangez trois
pommes bientôt vous êtes à 51 kg 1 89 2
tours de fesses on peut dire parce
qu'ils appellent sa hanche mais en fait
c'est face vous avez perdu 2 taille de
soutien gorge vous n'avez plus vos
règles
l'objectif reste quand même 47 kg et une
taille trop ne vous êtes pas encore un
soir c'est l'anniversaire de mariage de
vos parents votre père est un petit peu
inquiet sur votre façon de vous nourrir
il vous oblige à manger une assiette de
légumes vapeur jusque là tout va bien à
peine l'avez-vous terminer cette
assiette vous allez aux toilettes pour
faire vomir oui je n'ai pas réussi parce
que j'étais tellement angoissé d'avoir
mangé un plat entier au lieu d'une seule
pomme que je me suis dit faut que
j'élimine ça ouais et comme je n'ai pas
réussi à vomir j'ai pris des lacs cette
idée voilà quand vous arrivez à new york
vous êtes à 47 kg vous faites une
quinzaine de casting par jours sans
manger
absolument il sait courir sans manger et
finalement d'être mannequin on passe
d'un casting à l'autre et on peut
littéralement rien manger on en oublie
finalement la fin et ça c'est la spirale
de l'anorexie aussi on
on ne sent plus la fin normalement et
pour être honnête cette expérience de
défiler vous décrivez ça quand même
comme un chute de drogues dures c'est à
dire la musique les lumières des flashs
des applaudissements vous aimez sa
victoire ah oui ça c'est exceptionnel et
je comprends que ça fasse rêver parce
qu'effectivement il ya une adrénaline
absolument incroyable c'est galvanisant
en fait vous êtes entré dans une prison
dorée voilà
alors là évidemment shelly tout le monde
me félicite de votre poids tout le monde
vous applaudis mais vous avez honte car
vous savez que vous êtes à 49 et 49
c'est trop pour entrer dans du trône de
et tout est un échec c'est à dire que si
vous prenez un gramme si vous mangez un
aliment en plus c'est un échec parce
qu'il faut être dans le contrôle total
et là vous découvrez une nouvelle
technique d'amaigrissement les lavements
oui c'est à dire qu'au bout d'un moment
les laxatifs ne marchait plus on prenait
2 puis 4 puis une tablette de et tout le
paquet et j'ai signé du coup par me
faire des lavements tous les soirs
donc après les défilés vous entamer la
saison des shootings et là vous
découvrez un truc incroyable cirque ou
fait des photos mais en fait le gars le
photographe vous vous photoshop parce
qu'ils ne trouvent pas vrai elle là vous
êtes photoshopée la wii partout mais
c'est à dire que là on a rajouté des
joues on a gommé les zones au sternum on
a gommé les eaux de mon ventre on m'a
rajouté des cuisses voilà donc on nous
rajoute les kilos qu'on nous interdit de
prendre déjà pour les photos on vous
photoshop pour vous rendre plus
pulpeuses
et puis un jour alors que vous vous
déshabiller pour prendre un bain votre
mère vous regardez vous dise enfin on
dirait que tu sors dans le camp de
concentration
j'étais en train de de chercher tout le
gras que je n'avais pas sur mon corps et
j'étais désespéré parce que je me
trouvais énorme et elle est terreau
allemands tombés par terre en pleurant
et en me disant mais tu vas mourir on
dirait que tu sors d'un camp et moi je
lui répondais mais tu ne vois pas que je
suis énorme c'était une incompréhension
totale à partir de là vous avez beau
faire partie du classement des 20 top
model de l'année on a beau vous proposer
la couverture du magazine vague ce qui
est encore mieux mais vous avez déjà
lâché la rampe fait des crises de
boulimie j'avais votre âge on nous
appelle au fond c'est là à la
boulangerie vous acheter des
viennoiseries ne faisait que manger
effectivement j'avais peur quand mon
agent ma plaie jusqu'à faire une
tentative de suicide vous faites
victoire une tentative de suicide vous
avalez
plein de médoc heureusement votre frère
léo entre dans la chambre et vous sors
de là vous vous réveillez aux urgences
en vous afin lavement mais cette fois de
l'estomac
diagnostic est assez dur à ce moment là
déjà pas de règles pendant huit mois
ensuite des risques de stérilité
ostéoporose j'avais a dit mets tout mon
squelette j'avais perdu la moitié de mes
cheveux j'avais abîmé mais dans ma peau
enfin toutes les carences au monstre
aise quand vous êtes sorti de la
clinique on vous appelle de new york
vous dites m'attendent et je pèse 69 kg
et la fille billie c'est pas grave c'est
dans trois mois absolument donc le cycle
recommence est il ne l'a jamais dit
c'est pour ça que c'est extrêmement dur
d'en sortir est
aujourd'hui ça va fête du 38 vivait à
londres nous croisons encore des petites
sommes noirs
wee man ans maintenant
ça fait des années que je vous entends
dire que toutes ces machines sont
malheureuses ce soir vous avez des à
preuve il faut savoir que c'est c'est ce
monde là qui culpabilise l'autre monde
va dire qu'on vraiment en fabrique du
foot c'était que du mensonge
donc si c'est magnifique que vous ayez
le courage d'en parler parce que c'est
quand même que du mensonge comme on voit
que vous êtes photoshopée alors que vous
êtes d'une minceur incroyable et d'une
beauté incroyable ce 10 mai c'est fou ce
qu'on arrive à mettre dans la tête des
gens et des femmes et des jeunes filles
pour leur faire croire que c'est ça le
bonheur et et je suis sûr que c'est un
bel exemple qu'il faut que vous puissiez
en parler très souvent très souvent très
souvent pour que les jeunes filles sache
que ce que ça représente que vous êtes
des objets et des personnes exact
pour être sûr de ne rien rater de linars
10 tubes abonnez vous mettez un pouce
bleus